[Music]
they call you mystic Mac because you
have an eerie way of being able to
predict what's going to happen what's
your prediction then for this fight I
feel he is repetitive and his foot
patterns he is almost stuck in a routine
his shots are the same over and over his
retreat is the same over and over I feel
there are many shots of my book that
will land I like the left uppercut
although he has the right the height in
the range I still like that rear
uppercut and then I also like them a
lure which is the Halfmoon it's a it's a
cup of where a technique where you spin
and put your hand on the mat and swing
your heel around like a baseball but
it's it's a technique I have become very
good at and I am getting better at it so
I think I might break it out and ping it
across his head I think us I think that
is an effective that you put in her head
you put your hand down and swing around
like that Jackie is this frightening you
right now I mean I could do it if you
want to I don't
I don't
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
I don't want to go please don't if you
really hit me I will die before you hit
me but just give them a demonstration
this is wait you can go wherever you
want I'll go with you she's strong
okay and you and then we'll just go
right across my face and then I would
die incredible
[Applause]
you got that close you know that love my
favorite thing about the replay is my
face long before you hit me I'm like hey
this is a real honor Conor McGregor's
good luck to you sir
you